y el ph del refresco es de 3.37 después
de agregar el sorbato de potasio que
especie el ácido sórbico o el ión
sorbato tiene una mayor concentración en
el refresco justifica tu respuesta bueno
esto está relacionado con lo que hemos
estado haciendo porque el ión sorbato
esto es lo que pasa cuando el sorbato de
potasio se disocia en la solución
entonces podemos decir que la
concentración de lyon sorbato es igual a
la concentración del sorbato de potasio
y si llevamos a cabo la titulación del
sorbato de potasio que es lo que hemos
estado analizando en las diferentes
partes del problema en qué punto la
concentración del sorbato de potasio es
igual a la del ácido sórbico bueno las
concentraciones son iguales en el punto
medio de equivalencia miren aquí ya lo
habíamos marcado cuando hicimos esta
parte del problema y vimos que el punto
medio de equivalencia ocurre
un ph.d vamos a ver por qué eso también
ya lo habíamos calculado 44 puntos 77
entonces podemos decir que el punto
medio de equivalencia el punto medio de
equivalencia
de la titulación
del sorbato de potasio
de potasio con ácido clorhídrico
ocurre
a un ph de 4.77 y este es el punto en el
que las concentraciones son iguales lo
pondré entre paréntesis se puede ver
como el punto
en el que tenemos en el que tenemos
y las mismas concentraciones
16 h 7 ó 2 menos
de ácido sórbico a 16 h 7 a 2
entonces si tenemos un ph de 3.37
h de 3.37 como es menor
y ocurrirá
después del punto medio de equivalencia
entonces la concentración del ácido
sórbico es mayor entonces la
concentración
del ácido sórbico
hc 6h 72
mayor ok entonces cuando empezamos la
titulación la concentración de sorbato
de potasio era mayor pero al seguir
titulando empieza a reaccionar con el
ácido clorhídrico hasta que llegamos al
punto medio de equivalencia en el que
las concentraciones de estas dos
especies serán iguales pero cómo
seguimos titulando la solución se vuelve
más y más ácida y por lo tanto tendremos
una concentración mayor de ácido sórbico
entonces una forma de verlo es que voy a
subrayar lo la concentración del ácido
sórbico es mayor eso es lo que nos están
preguntando y entonces una forma de
verlo es que este refresco podríamos
decir que en este refresco al llegar a
ese punto en la titulación en el que
pasamos el punto medio de equivalencia
lo que nos interesa es este ácido contra
su base conjugada entonces la mayoría
del ácido sórbico
está en su forma ácida o dicho de otra
forma el sorbato se convierte en el
ácido conjugado